افاد مراسل الجزيره بان الجزائر وزعت
مشروع قرار على اعضاء مجلس الامن يطالب
بوقف فوري لاطلاق النار لاسباب انسانيه في
قطاع غزه ويجدد مشروع القرار الدعوه الى
وصول المساعدات الانسانيه بشكل كامل وسريع
وامن ودون عوائق الى قطاع غزه باكمله
ويرفض مشروع القرار التهجير القصريه
للسكان المدنيين الفلسطينيين بما في ذلك
الاطفال في انتهاك للقانون الدولي ويطالب
بوقف كافه هذه الانتهاكات يشير مشروع
القرار في مقدمه الى الامر الذي اصدرته
محكمه العدل الدوليه في الساس من الشهر
المنصرم والذي يشير الى اتخاذ تدابير
مؤقته في القضيه المتعلقه بتطبيق اتفاقيه
منع جريمه الاباده الجماعيه والعاقبه
عليها وقال مصدر دبلوماسي للجزيره ان
المسوده ما تزال في المراحل الاولى من
التفاوض ومن غير المرجح ان يتم التصويت
عليها هذا الاسبوع
للمتابعه معنا من نيويورك مراسل جزيره
مراد هاشم مراد الى اي مدى يبدو ان هنالك
توافقا دوليا فيما يتعلق بهذا الطرح يعني
نتحدث هنا عن التفسير بان تطبيق قرار
محكمه العدل الدوليه يتطلب وقفا فوريا
لاطلاق
النار
مراد لا ادري اذا كنت تسمعني الان مراد
اذا كنت تسمعني كنت سالتك عن التوافقات
الدوليه اذا كان هنالك توافق دولي فيما
يتعلق
بفكره الوقف الفوري لاطلاق
النار نعم نشوان هناك اجماع كبير
ل الدعوه لوقف اطلاق النار عبر مج مجلس
الامن وعبر قرار من مجلس الامن الدولي هذا
امر يكاد يكون هناك اجماع كبير عليه
الاستثناءات
البسيطه تتعلق بالموقف الامريكي وهو موقف
حاسم وفاعل في مجلس الامن
الدولي باعتبار ان انها دوله دائمه
العضويه وهي استخدمت البيتو كما هو معروف
اكثر من مره لاجهاض اكثر من مشروع
قرار
كانت قرارات او مشروعات تدعو الى وقف
اطلاق النار بشكل صريح ولعل ما الال هذا
المشروع الجديد ايضا فيتو امريكي الامر
متوقع بشكل كبير المندوبه الامريكيه في
جلسه مجلس
الامن الاربعاء قالت
ان قرارات القرارات المؤقته لمحكمه العدل
الدوليه لم تدعو بشكل صريح الى وقف اطلاق
النار وبالتالي فان ال من يدعون من
الاعضاء الى ان يدعم مجلس الامن الدولي
امرا كهذا هو امر غير واقعي ولا اساسا له
كما اشارت بطبيعه الحال طرح المشروع من
الواضح كبدايه لانطلاق المفاوضات التصويت
عليه متوقع ان يكون الاسبوع القادم لاتاحه
المجال لمزيد من المفاوضات حول هذا
المشروع اذا لم يمر هذا المشروع سيكون
ايضا كما ال عدد من شاريع القرارات على
الاقل هناك مشروعين كان في مجلس الامن
وطرح على الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده
حيث حصل على اغلبيه كبيره اخر مشروع حصل
على 153 صوتا داعما وكان يتضمن اي دعوه
صريحه لوقف اطلاق النار لاسباب انسانيه
وهي ذات الصيغه الوارده في هذا المشروع
المطروح الان هذا المشروع يستفيض وستسحب
كثيرا في الحيثيات والمرجعيات مما في ذلك
المطالبه بالمسائل المسائله على انتهاكات
القانون الانساني الدولي وكذلك الاهم من
ذلك يعتبر ان الوضع في غزه يشكل تهديد
الامن والسلم الدوليين بطبيعه الحال هذه
اللغه قد يصار الى مراجعتها ا بانتظار
ايضا ان تقدم الدول الاعضاء في مجلس الامن
ملاحظاتها على هذه الصيغه يوم الجمعه
ستتواصل المفاوضات حول هذه الصيغه ولكن
التوقعات تشير الى موقف امريكي
اي قد يكون رافضا وحاسما ولا سيما للبند
المتعلق بالدعوه لوقف اطلاق نار لاسباب
انسانيه نشوان